In the US, Harvey Weinstein, disgraced film producer,...
...was found guilty of sexual assault on two counts...
...and found not guilty on the two other rape charges against him.
This all comes after over 60 women coming forward to accuse him of assault,...
...causing the resurgence of the "Me Too" movement in 2017.
In India, US President Donald Trump and his wife Melania visited the Taj Mahal...
...after being welcomed by tens of thousands of people...
...at a reception held in a 110,000-seat cricket stadium in Gujarat.
A seventh person infected with the coronavirus has died in Italy...
...with more than 200 cases reported there since Friday.
A total of 2,628 people have died worldwide from the virus and more than 79,000 are infected.
Reports cite a war monitor as saying Israeli air strikes...
...targeting the Islamic Jihad militant group in the Gaza Strip and Syria...
...have killed at least six fighters, after the jihadists fired rockets at Israel.
Finally from Germany, around 30 people were injured...
...after a car ploughed into a carnival parade in the western German town of Volkmarsen.
The driver was a 29-year-old German citizen...
...who acted deliberately and specifically targeted children according to eyewitnesses.